Why can't birds fly in space?
They want to, but I keep on bringing them back.
What? Oh AumSum.
How birds fly can be best explained using Bernoulli's principle.
Wings of the birds play a major role in this.
The shape of their wings causes air to move much faster above their wings....
...as compared to the air moving below their wings.
This difference in air pressure pushes up on their wings, creating a lift.
Thus allowing a bird to fly.
Also, definition of "to fly" is to move in or pass through air with wings.
Now, space is a vacuum, it has no air.
Thus, without air a bird will not be able to fly.
Finally, even if birds were able to fly in space they will not be able to swallow food.
Why?
Because birds depend on gravity to push their food downwards.
Why do birds crash in to windows?
Because they don't ring bells and walk through doors.
Oh AumSum.
It is estimated that close to a billion birds crash in to windows...
...and die in the US each year.
Firstly, researchers believe that just like humans,...
...even birds are not able to see transparent glass.
Humans can anticipate the presence of transparent glass...
...based on some visual clues like frames or knobs.
But birds lack the ability to do so.
Secondly, it is believed that collisions occur more frequently during breeding season.
As birds, after seeing their own reflection in the window...
...misjudge it for a different bird and attack it.
Lastly, it is also believed that birds perceive the reflected images in the glass...
...to be real objects.
Hence, collisions occur more often...
...when glass is reflecting the images of food or shelter.